the last time we were together
one-on-one was the first time we kissed
and we were like 13 my parents sent me
to this Retreat Camp I was trying to
make a fire I don't know how long and
then I saw someone like come over here I
like really need assistance ended up
like making the fire so we were both
like have you had your first kiss I was
like yeah we I guess we can be each
other's first kisses or whatever and it
was like gave each other like three
kisses yeah we were sweaty and like very
disgusting but it still felt very
magical having an experience like that
really young is very freeing definitely
made me reevaluate just attraction in
general I want to like pretend to make
the fire again okay ready ready let's
kiss then the fire
starts I know she'll be in my life for
many more years I think we should do
this like every seven years